five things an actor should not do
during an audition everything's on the
table tell them how funny the material
is or how well it's written that's
insulting because you know this is
really funny well how did you think it
was gonna be so that's one I would say
don't ask them to validate your parking
don't say usually when I put me on tape
I'm not wearing anything okay unless
you're in the valley you guys alright I
think one thing you shouldn't do is you
shouldn't shake hands with anyone they
shouldn't presume that someone's gonna
someone's gonna greet you openly Wow
well I have failed all of these I'm like
this is so funny and I give them a hug
[Laughter]
let's see you know for me it's just
don't overthink like just go like I've
just I don't I just say hey this is my
gift to you have fun instead of like is
this what you want I never think that I
think hi this is my gift microphone job
and you just okay so that's why you
don't work more ok so then once you get
the job 5 things an actor does on set
that are huge mistakes direct another
actor I think sit in somebody's chair
sit an executive whose chair is an actor
or just go to catering and shut up yeah
I think just showing up like what
bothers me is you have 200 person crew
people wake up at 4:00 in the morning
you know they're spending 17 hours a day
and I really don't like when people
aren't prepared that's my big thing like
to me acting is like tennis you can't
out act somebody you throw them the ball
depending on how they hit the ball to
you is how you hit it bad
so to me it's just be really prepared I
think even if that means whatever your
weave it's like not knowing the lines at
all but you kind of know what the scenes
about whatever you know the lines inside
out you know whatever it is but I just
feel like it's really disrespectful if
people are like figuring it out there
well everyone is like just waiting right
I really think is like the worst thing
no I think that's really even before
someone's coverage like you go somewhere
and then you're not there for the other
oh yeah you have to go you have to go to
dinner or something
and they're gonna act with you because I
gotta go yeah they'll be like actor this
piece of tape or talk louder about
something that nobody cares about which
would be their own life for this film
did Ben and Joe allow you just to improv
a dialogue or were they very strict with
the script I think we kept to the script
I mean there's a lot of information in
there and there's you know a lot of
pertinent important information and I
think we it was good to stick to it I
mean there were moments and we got to
play and have some fun but I think this
the script it's so well written I think
if we played within the script we were
good you know I think that maybe you
guys what add Libyan is only good in
comedies I don't think it's good and
dramatic because I gonna make it sadder
or more dramatic wow he's really dead
you know it's already you know you don't
so dramatic drama doesn't really yeah
well the only the only the only improv
that I did was just add Spanish which
Ben was cool I said look they're having
this really intimate conversation and
they've been together forever and I just
feel like she would speak Spanish to him
and he was like please you know so
there's a couple things that I said in
that scene that I just said I just spoke
Spanish to him but other than that yeah
it's so well-written you just don't have
to mess with was there chemistry between
you two because I don't see it in the
movie but was it
was there not that's the sixth thing you
don't do once yeah you guys got along no
it's very sweet you really important I
mean Ben and Joe had us meet well before
we even went out to shoot the movie and
I think that was I think that added to
the chemistry I think he gave us a
little bit of history before he walked
on set in that way you know I think that
was important that we spend time before
we landed in Calgary yeah and when we
met Joe for the first time Joe's like
you guys have known each other forever
and I said and they said and he said Ben
how long have they known each other and
and we're like we just met an hour ago
and Joe couldn't believe it the member
we like I went out for tequila and he
picks me up and by the time the car ride
ended we just I don't know I felt like I
known you for so you know just last
story anything that happened on set
where it seemed like it was going to be
a disaster and then at the last minute
something happened and it pulled it all
together how much time do you have no I
mean it's you know it's independent
filmmaking so there's all kinds of
little disasters but it's how well
people deal with them and that's kind of
part of filmmaking it's at least in
television you develop a rhythm to
shooting and in television it's over and
by the time you start developing
something you know this kind of rhythm
so but it you can really tell the
character of the of the crew and how
they handle those all those little those
little you know accidents and I think
the crew just it was it was well you
know everyone gelled really well and
felt with adversity and all the in the
best way you know you can ask what we we
have a scene he and I in the ambulance
and it's very tight so as I was laying
down I'm over there and the paramedic is
I mean he really was acting you're gonna
be all right he's getting in front of
the camera
Ben's like hey that dude this dude used
to bring it down a little bit so I think
he just ended up not talking and put in
an IV in just take it easy
he's ordering a hearse around there's no
nurse in there so I think that there's a
you can you can do too much because it's
the one thing you know he holds it up I
think this is gonna work he is
unrecognizable in this film like his
dramatic work as an actor is piercing
and grounded and connected and I really
am so proud I just want to say that I'm
very you got me to read the script five
months I she was telling me how great
the movie was and I didn't you know I'm
golfing at Tenerife so it was gonna go
away and she said really really like I'm
telling you don't miss this opportunity
I'm glad and I'm glad that you know I
partially read it flexing Matt what you
just give me the exact repeated
Britannica to look at exactly NOPD is
what I call it the exact exact OPD up
thank you